good afternoon my name is Dino Varkey
I'm the group executive director and
board member of for gems education which
is the the leading k-12 education
company in the world today when talking
about the youth unemployment crisis too
often there is a focus on the quality
and provision of tertiary sector higher
education and whether it's matching up
with the jobs that private sector in the
economy require from my perspective
that's too late in the game to be
focusing on this issue the reality is
this we need to be focusing on primary
education and that is where you build
the underlying skills and fundamentals
and our young people that will hold them
in good stead in order to enter the job
market so from my perspective it's not a
solution it's just refocusing our
priority where it matters most and that
is in terms of primary and secondary
education